in the transcriptomics one course we
cover key concepts needed to understand
the analysis of gene expression data
we've already discussed how genes are
expressed in the cell and what methods
are available to detect and quantify
expression in this video we will focus
on the analytical steps used a process
next generation sequencing data
next-generation sequencing technology
allows for advanced studies of gene
expression because it captures a
snapshot of the whole transcriptome
rather than a predetermined subset of
genes which was previously possible with
rt-pcr and microarray technologies
whole transcriptome sequencing provides
a comprehensive view of the cellular
transcriptional profile at a given
biological moment and greatly enhances
the power of RNA discovery methods to
study this data we have to understand
and run processing pipelines that turn
raw reads into structured data ready for
analysis next-generation sequencing is a
technology that captures DNA sequences
and generates digital data using several
steps first RNA that was extracted from
cells is converted to cDNA that is then
sheared and placed into a flow cell
inside the flow cell cDNA fragments are
amplified using bridge PCR amplification
and the flow cell is then inserted into
the sequencer this machine uses image
analysis to capture each letter in the
flow cell fragments by analyzing visual
patterns as well as converting them into
a sequence of letters typically NGS
reads are between 30 and 300 base pairs
long
they consist of a series of letters T C
G ma the main question now is how to
analyze these sequences to find which
genes they came from to better
understand these steps and how they
influence analysis let's take a look at
the sequence elements that we'll be
capturing in the process this is the
reference genome where you have gene a
gene B and G and C not everything is
transcribed for example gene a and gene
C are transcribed but gene B is not the
product that is transcribed is an RNA
isoform or transcript of the gene as
it's encoded in DNA this transcript gets
shattered as it converted into cDNA
fragments
adapters are attached at the beginning
in the end of each fragment the
nucleotide information is amplified
using PCR and is only then read by the
sequencer as a result we get reads which
are short sequences of genetic code that
are stored in fast queue files
sequencing can be single or pair end
pair and sequencing combines two reads
that were sequence from opposite ends of
a DNA fragment because the reads contain
overlapping sequences they can be merged
into a single read that is more reliable
however the reads are stored in separate
files in the case of parrot and
sequencing each sample will have to fast
queue files you can see it in the file
names file names ending with underscore
one and underscore two will be used to
name paired-end sequence data inside
each fast QL labels are used to name
each read then we'll see the sequence of
that read and the quality score for each
nucleotide letter the reads have to be
aligned to the reference genome to find
where they came from they will be
aligned using match quality to the
sequence of the genes then the number of
the reads across the gene sequence will
be quantified to give us a level of
expression the alignment process is also
known as mapping and it is a procedure
that determines a score even for a short
read finding its place in the genome can
be computationally expensive the human
genome is over 3 billion base pairs long
the best match is determined by how
close the sequences to the read on the
sequence of the reference genome let's
take a look at the reads alignment to
the reference genome by running our
first pipeline once the files are loaded
in the start function we can use bowtie
2 to align the reads to the reference
genome and visualize alignment coverage
and alignment quality using the
visualization method bowtie 2 is an
algorithm that utilizes the
burrows-wheeler algorithm to make
alignments of short reads to a long
sequence of the reference genome as a
result we will see the visualization of
reads aligned at the reference genome
the sample name is mentioned here and
can have multiple layers of information
for alignment
coverage shows how many reads align to
the region and alignment visualize the
types of reads and any changes that
might be observed from the reference
genome this visualization is taking
information from the alignment file
which is stored in Sam or BAM formats
and is used in many subsequent steps of
analysis let's take a look at the
different files that are used to compile
this visualization sequencing data is
stored in several different file formats
for example fast queue files provide us
with reads from the sequencer fast a is
a text-based format for representing DNA
and protein sequences typically this is
the reference file for the genome then
we have the genome transfer format or
GTF file which contains genome
annotation for example the GTF will
store the start and end of each genomic
element which are exons isoforms and
genes to process next-generation
sequencing data
we must map reads onto the reference
genome to do so we have to make sure we
know where on the genome we have exons
this information is in the GTF file then
we take the sequences from the fast
queue file where we have short reads to
align to some annotated position on the
genome the genome reference gives us
information on where the gene is located
and what exons are on that gene then as
different isoforms are created from the
single gene reference different reads
are mapped on the specific exons they
are mapped in different quantities as
fast q files that give different
sequences of the reads as you can see
from this GTF example on chromosome 15
we have an exon that starts and ends at
a specific place and belongs to a given
gene and transcript ID etc a typical RNA
seek pipeline includes three main steps
pre-processing mapping and
quantification pre-processing is needed
to clean up our data by removing the
adapters trimming some of the reads and
removing the PCR duplicates this is
important because PCR amplification is
not uniform across all reads then we
take the cleaned up
read sequences to map them onto a
reference using a fast day file for
sequences of the genome and GTF files
for annotation based on the quality of
annotation we can use various strategies
for mapping once this step is complete
we have to quantify the expression
levels and give each expressed element a
number in the beginning uploaded files
have to be unzipped - with pairs
prepared together in the right reference
and the pipeline folder structure built
the start button runs these scripts at
the beginning of the pipeline cleaning
reads from unwanted variation can make a
large difference to the speed and
quality of mapping and assembly results
these steps include removing reads
and/or bases that are from unwanted
sequences such as poly a tails and RNA
seek data bases that artificially added
on to the sequence of primary interest
such as vectors adapters and primers
bases that join short overlapping pair
end reads low-quality bases or bases
that originated from PCR duplication
pre-processing also produces a number of
statistics that are used to evaluate
experimental consistency bow tie to
g-star and bwa our alignment algorithms
that look for optimal positions of
mapping on a read to the reference
genome a variety of algorithms have been
introduced to improve the speed
efficiency and flexibility of the
algorithms when considering standard
genomic variations like insertions
deletions and rearrangements isoform
construction and merging of isoforms in
the GTF file occurs once the reads are
aligned to the reference genome with
abundant area is considered to be exons
reads then are analyzed to find those
that contain the end of one exon in the
beginning of another identifying them as
junctions
once all junctions are identified exon
spliced together are assigned to an
isoform
isoforms are recorded in the updated GTF
file cuff merge is responsible for
updating the GTF file where positions of
exons and their order in each isoform
are stored top hat and high side are
versions of the same algorithm that
combines several steps such as exon
detection isoform construction and the
merging of the GTF file once the
annotation of alignment patterns and
genomic elements are available
have to be realigned to this information
for quantification a typical pipeline
will combine these methods into a
sequence of scripts or algorithms that
can produce certain outputs useful for
further steps for example after the
files are loaded it can be aligned to
the genome using bowtie to G and then
visualized an alternative route can use
alignment - known transcripts and ignore
any transcription variation we can find
in a given set of samples we can also
run more detailed pipelines that will
map on the genome identify exon
junctions and link them into isoforms
this creates a transcriptome not being
reads to the transcriptome and
quantifying all found transcripts during
the quantification step different
algorithms generate specific files that
can be useful in some subsequent step so
the pipeline will limit connections
between steps that do not have
appropriate file outputs to make the
pipeline function properly one major
difference between these pipelines is
the mapping step we can use known
transcripts to find the ones transcribed
in a given data set by using different
mapping strategies the difference is in
the output and time that it will take to
process a data set
after the mapping is complete we have to
quantify RNA expression there are three
ways that this can be done raw counts
are PKM fpkm
and TPM these are normalization
techniques that are typically used to
eliminate the variation caused by
differences in coverage and sample
quality fpkm stands for fragment per
kilo base per million of map reads this
approach will quantify expression
normalized for the total number of reads
available as well as the reads divided
by gene link our p km is the same as
fpkm but an application to single end
reads TPM does not consider the length
of the gene and averages all reads
dividing the read count by a million now
that we reviewed the theoretical part
let us run the pipeline's of practice
what we have learned the first pipeline
is the most simple we will load the data
and quantify it using an alignment free
quantification the result will be quick
but we might find that while all
possible transcripts are included we
will have many with zero expression
levels that means that we will have to
work more with the output table
another issue we'll notice
that selfish will quantify transcripts
and not genes in some cases this will
require additional steps to make gene
expression tables the second pipeline we
can build will include pre-processing
steps and then use the GTF file with our
seventh quantification to set a set of
standard outputs filtered gene and ISO
form expression tables in raw count and
fpkm units we can leverage the top hat
or high sat option to build a pipeline
that will map on the genome and
construct new isoforms from this sample
set the resulting tables will be
different from the previous pipeline
because we mapped on the genome and
possible new isoforms can be found in
the output file the same pipeline can
contain pre-processing steps typically
pre-processing steps with the most
visible in the genes that are highly
expressed in the dataset after high sat
or top hat to an alternative method for
quantification can be used HTC is a
Python library that was designed to
facilitate parsing of common data
formats and high-throughput sequencing
projects as well as classes to represent
data such as genomic coordinates
sequencing reads alignments gene model
information and variant calls and
provides data structures that allow for
quiring via genomic coordinates finally
we can use a more detailed approach to
analyze the way reads align to the
reference genome Augustus is a method
that starts with exon detection and then
looks for junctions between identified
exons this method will have the most
accurate and specific results for
non-standard gene isoform variations
often time this pipeline will be
reserved for non-model organisms where a
well annotated GTF file is not available
a typical output from these pipelines
will vary but for the most part results
will be clearly organized by element
such as exon isoform and gene we will
also see normalized and filtered tables
of gene or isoform expression we can
also check the quality of our mapping by
looking at the mapping statistics file
we've processed the raw read sequences
quantified them and now have structured
data where columns are sample names and
rows or gene or isoform IDs and in Samba
format
inside each cell we will find the
quantified expression level depending on
the quantification level this number can
be fpkm rpkm TPM or raw count units
looking through the resulting table you
will notice that some genes start with
the letter e NSG and some start with ENS
mus these show mouse and human genes and
isoforms since we used a concatenated
human mouse genome we can separate the
stroma from the tumor expression the
bars on the bar chart show an expression
profile now we can work with this table
and further explore the expression
profiles of specific genes gene sets and
annotate them by their biological
functions in the transcriptomics 1
course we covered key concepts needed to
understand the analysis of gene
expression data in this video we focused
on the analytical steps needed to
process next-generation sequencing data